hello my name is larry arn i'm the
president of hillsdale college
and i'm standing here in the place where
you will have your first experience with
hillsdale college right behind me by
central hall
you'll pick up a packet on sunday august
23rd now normally i would address you
for the first time on august 24th and i
will
this time too but i value that
experience and value that it's first
well now we have to do this unusual
thing
and the reason is there's a bunch of
astonishing stuff happening in the world
of course the virus is astonishing but
another astonishing thing is first of
all
some colleges are announcing that they
are not intending to have
in-person classes in the fall and uh it
hadn't occurred to us
that we wouldn't have college but now it
has because people ask us
well of course we're going to have
college and i'm going to give you the
reasons there are several and they're
very powerful reasons and the first one
is this is what we do
when you come here you're going to meet
the challenge of learning
what things are in reality any
fundamental thing
that word fundamental it means down at
the foundation
we are humans what does that mean to be
human
it means we have to work we'll starve if
we don't
also by our work we shape our characters
and inform our intellects
and so we are supposed to be about our
work i
am astonished that there's this
abstraction
called the economy and the thought is we
can turn it off and turn it on at will
because that's not how it works we have
to live
we are a beings in motion with a
contemplative side
this is what we do we've been doing it
for 175 years
we are going to keep doing it and of
course in the 175 years there have been
many
obstacles the civil war right over there
is our war memorial statue from that war
and we had a big part in that war
and all the big wars and the great
depression and we weathered those and
we're going to weather this
in fact we're going to weather this
easier than those the second thing is
this is what this thing we do is
beautiful
um that word beautiful is a big word
it is in certain classic works
the perfection of the word good and the
good is the being of
anything what it is you're going to find
out
what you are you're going to approach
the study of that and every fundamental
thing
as if there is a reality and that's a
very strange thing to do because
what colleges teach today is things are
just whatever you make of them
you should recreate yourself be your own
god
well we don't think that we're actually
going to get to do that because here we
these bipeds with the rational soul
what is that how does that work and to
learn that
of course we're going to get back
together and do that
and if by some wicked chance
the law doesn't let us do it
then we won't i don't think that's going
to happen
but if that does happen we're going to
find a way to turn that to good
just like we found a way this time so
look around here right i look forward to
seeing you
on august 23rd